and he goes I know where you're going
with this he said here's the deal it's
taken me a year and a half to put this
staff together and we're the Saturday
Night Live of radio he said there isn't
a bad shift every one of my DJs is
exactly where they should be and they're
great he said they're all going to have
a job when they come back and I'm afraid
I won't have a position for you and I
looked at him and I said Rick when you
hear me on the air you'll give me a
job and he said okay and so I I I went I
went on the air quit K&C and I loved KC
so much and the people there nor McBride
the morning guy and Jimmy Christopher
the the uh program director I didn't
want to steal any audience from them
because they had a little only a little
signal so I changed my name from dick
Shephard and I didn't know what to call
myself and even I went on the air that
day and I still didn't know what to call
myself and I'm flipping desperately
through the Los Angeles Times and I see
Robert Hilbert the critic and I'm like
Richard Hilburn n no no and I wanted to
go back to Richard from dick Richard
Hilburn no no that's not going to work
it's as bad as Richard Shepherd I want
something else and I see Blade Runner is
going to open in two weeks didn't know
what the movie was about no one knew it
hadn't opened yet it was going to open
in two weeks time so I Richard Blade
that would work great so I this was
where newspapers were yay big right so I
drop it on the floor and the song's
finishing and I come on the air and I go
uh that was seag goals and
telecommunication but the fans call it
Telecom uh by the way this is not Jed
the fish this is me I'm sitting in for
Jed the fish he's in Hawaii right now my
name is and I'd forgotten because I was
so panicked that everyone in everyone in
La was listening I looked down and the
papers folded oh I was going to call
myself Richard Runner sorry oh cuz Blade
Runner blade Rich Runner and I was going
to steal the RR of rollsroyce I thought
that would be a great thing you know and
all that Richard you forgot yeah but I
forgot and I look down and it's folded
and it just says blade and I went I'm
Richard Blade and this is OMD
electricity and I started the song and I
went oh Richard Blade don't guess I'm
stuck with that so that's how that came
about and that was it that was it so
this took off you while you were there
you really showed him like people wanted
to listen to you they had no other
choice than to give you a job well yeah
yeah kind of what happened that first
day was uh
elvar and Danny Elfman were going to
follow me alvarro was going to do the um
evening show and Danny was going to do
the afternoon show I was on till noon
and then Danny was going to be in for
Jed the fish uh because I was in for Den
Denise Westwood and then for Freddy
snakeskin it was going to be alvara and
so I do my three-hour show get to noon
say goodbye see you
tomorrow 12 or five rolls around no 1210
no no Danny first no Danny so then the
hotline rings and this voice comes on he
goes hey who's this on the air and I I
said it's Richard Blade Richard Runner
Rich BL he goes this is this is Danny he
said I said oh cool are you on your way
and he said no I I can't get in today he
said we're rehearsing for a tour and
Johnny vatos has this thing that he
needs us to do and Johnny was the
drummer and so I'm going to miss today
can you fill for me so I said sure I'll
fil so hang up do another three hours so
now I've done six hours on the air and
get to the end of the six hours and say
thanks so much bye and
then it's now 3:00 at 3:10 comes no
elvir so I walk out where are you yeah
so exactly what I said to the girl at
the front desk I said have you heard
anything from oir she go oh you didn't
get the message so no she said she's
running late she's taping her Mistress
of the dark for Channel 9 right now so
she won't you're filling in for that
yeah so I did N 9 hours straight and in
the final hour of my show at 5:30 5:25
actually I'm reading an ad for the
parrot place in van and it's a live
commercial and they had U green mcalls
for sale that weekend for
$49.95 and I'm reading this live ad and
this whad guy walks in the studio and
goes where's snakes skin and I hit the
mic off I go I'm on the air right now
and I turn it back on so if you go on
down anytime this week through Sunday
night where's snakes skin I need to talk
to him I go he's not here he's in Hawaii
and I turned it back on and I said so go
and get these mcco and it's not just
mcco on sale I want snake skin where can
I get him I turned it off and I said
please I'm doing a live commercial and I
turn it back on and carry on reading and
he goes I want snakes skin I went get
the out of this studio or I will
throw you out and he looks at me and I
turn it on and finish the live read
finish my show 6:00 Pat Welsh the
general manager comes up and he goes you
were on for N9 hours and I said yeah and
he goes sounded pretty good to me and I
said great he goes I want you to meet
someone so he takes me back to his
office and I've met Pat Welsh before the
general manager uh just in passing when
I was doing the spots for the um radio
station and I walk in and the white hair
guy is sitting behind snakes skin no the
guy who said no the one he was ask
asking for Freddy snakes skin yeah he's
sitting behind Pat's desk Jes in Pat's
chair and I walk in with Pat and he
looks at me and then he turns his eyes
for me and he stares at Pat because he
doesn't want to look at me and he goes
ask the kid why he told me to
off and Pat goes why I said I heard him
and I just don't know how I did it but I
Ste forward wouldn't put my hands on the
desk and I put my face in his face and I
said as far as I know in radio and I've
worked for two other radio stations the
only way a radio station makes money is
by selling commercials if a stranger
walks in on my show and interrupts a
commercial the station's not going to
get paid